now you auditioned for Sandler's movie
right I did never without him never with
Adam was Adam in the room
uh no he wasn't even in the room no I
met Adam are you his love interest yeah
how are you doing good to see you all
right so good that's exactly what he
sounds like you look like Lopez
so then I audition it went really well
apparently I guess the tapes were seen
but I know that there was a little
um behind the scenes like I'd heard
later on that before they actually
offered the part to me Adam had sort of
called around
to be like
tell me about shriki like we're thinking
about her for this
is this a good thing is this about
really so they want to know if you were
easy to work with easy to work with
would I be able to hold my own opposite
him